what else what do you do with a hammer
you could use it to eat when you clean
it and it doesn't come off you panic
what's that believe nation today hate
and I are gonna be making above a a ball
aluminum foil magic
[Music]
we need a hammer
aluminum foil paper and Pollard alright
let's go get it
[Music]
[Music]
but remember it won't shrink
[Music]
just squeeze it together one last time
[Music]
take our hair we're gonna start smashing
until it gets to a nice try to make it
even so we you you'll notice that the
ball starts to get harder and harder
with your smack when you smash it more
because it breaks the layers together
now in yours there might be some cracks
so make sure to hammer that good so
it'll seal up daddy you need to keep
hammering away until it's perfect I was
the one that taught you the instructions
take the hammer and you hammer what else
what do you do with the hammer you could
use it this is the perfect
what is thank you
oh that's not good don't do this on a
countertop don't do this on a countertop
let's clean that up before and then when
you clean it and it doesn't come off you
don't do this on a nice countertop Wow
well that's not good I don't have a
solution apart from seeing this this is
really just my fault right Wow
Nina's not gonna be happy seeing that
okay well the good news is I think Nina
will have a solution to fix that and
until then we need to hammer on a
different surface like like a bag like a
bag a banana
should we hammer it on the banana or
hammer on the bag I think we go back is
this the perfect what do we need same
paper for I should also look up how to
clean aluminum foil marks from a
countertop pour white vinegar in a clear
clean spray bottle spray the cooking
surface of the grill with vinegar that's
neither grill a lot of vinegar to remain
on the surface a few minutes rub the
cooking surface of crumpled up
no it's rub it with a little file no no
Jo what can dissolve them Faro's is safe
to put it on the stove what can dissolve
a little foil salt vinegar acidic foods
Tomatoes the fall seems it is all good
eaten away but what happens it turns
into an aluminum salt why are you
laughing so like why are you laughing
we need to clean this mess up or vinegar
such as tomatoes let's try some vinegar
the only vinegar we have is apple cider
vinegar curtain shot pour some on just a
little bit
yeah really can you hold it all open it
hold I can't open it easy there you go
just a little bit don't make a big spill
mess yeah I can't get perfectly good
let's see no wipe it away apple cider
vinegar tis a clean aluminum foils marks
scrub scrub
look at that scrub look at how much it's
coming off
let's go harder it did nothing let me
try it did something please the glass
smells really bad uh
yeah nothing came on here so that was a
fail if any of you guys have suggestions
for how we could take our aluminum foil
stain off of our countertop that would
be awesome
let us know but right now we gotta go
get some sandpaper because I don't have
any in our condo to sand this down to
the car I put the one with the handle
yeah sanding block why is that the best
one
okay that's the one perfect spelling
pattern here there's a smell like can we
borrow some of those cleaning supplies
to fix our camera job we're not
surrounded by vinegar you think it'll
work
yeah did you miss the scheme oh we were
gone for seven and a half minutes did
you miss us
[Music]
and you want to swap okay you'll swap it
still smells like vinegar it's really
gross this isn't really working so far
it's been one minute and 10 seconds of
you doing that let me think about this
is it working this is looking good it's
it's definitely definitely good idea
doing on the by because well it's
looking more shiny is it yeah big of a
shiny
[Music]
daddy did none of that work I did all of
it every single one I did all of that so
what's the solution I think maybe you
need to like an electric sander
I think the electric sander would make
it better
I'll see you said this isn't my fault
it's my fault anyway though right
everything's my fault just hammer it
more is that our final ball I didn't
quite turn out like we wanted it to turn
out but those are some of the steps
involved so if you want to make the
actual silver ball of magic here's how
to do it
[Music]
so that's how you do it lessons learned
what do we learn what our lessons lay
use an electric sander don't do this on
your kitchen countertop without some
kind of protection with armor use armor
and then don't use and don't use a
banana good all right thank you guys so
much for watching we hope you enjoyed
please have confidence in yourself
I'll see you soon bye-bye
[Music]